Jimmy Rollins how you living welcome
inside look at this with us what Curtis
Granderson jrro Jimmy Rollins Albert
phol the Hall of Famer Pedro Martinez my
name is Lauren shahadi there is so much
to like about Philadelphia at the top of
the list Pedro Martinez listen to me
because I had to research it with Joe in
research to make sure it was true Philly
starting pitching this postseason 51
strikeouts four walks let that sink in
it is complete dominance it is and and
and
I I wouldn't say it's surprising because
I saw Philadelphia face Atlanta and I
saw how the everybody was pitching but
to do it against a team that's so pesky
like the Arizona Diamondbacks uh
especially the strikeouts really get my
attention and that is a pure sign of
great pitching and and great approach to
a team that I guess when when they were
playing Atlanta and they saw them play
those games they they were get getting
ready and and one other thing that's
where the analytics come into play I
think they did a great job at analyzing
those Arizona Diamond Backs uh uh
hitters and their their approach because
if you watch Willer and Nola go about
their business out there it was pretty
much the same thing they never felt
comfortable taking one a bat against
either one of the two guys and that is
rare that in in in the entire lineup you
don't find someone that feels a little
bit more comfortable against either one
and how about their offense I mean we
say all the time solo shots won't hurt
you 13 straight it is hurting the
diamond it's their recipe that's all
they do like get a pitch to hit and they
don't miss it and they hit it out of the
ballpark and then they just continue to
keep applying pressure even if they're
only up three nothing four nothing next
thing you know you look up you're down
five nothing you're down six nothing
like they just keep inching away at you
and just keeps sucking the life out of
you and they showed a prime example of
that again tonight they have every
ingredient to win right the lineup the
aces the two Aces you heard Kyle
schwarber talking about tonight as being
an ace as well and a bullpen for days
it's deep Jimmy yes they do and we can't
forget about the the third guy you know
the third head of monsters he says the
guy that NE doesn't necessarily have Ace
stuff but he has a ace mentality that's
Ranger szz underrated by the way very
underrated he's cool on the mounded K
swag I think something that is
underrated that maybe the Diamond Backs
weren't quite prepared for they're used
to going to Rogers they're used to
playing out west they hadn't come out
east and playing in this type of
atmosphere and when you hear about it
and you go into it and it's all that
you're dealing with more than just the
ball game it's that 10th man sitting on
your neck wanting you to do bad and then
their team doing well Albert you were
always the guy that pitchers went uh-uh
I'm not pitching to him I do not want to
face him the Phillies don't have a lot
of Albert pools but they have a lot of
guys who can hurt you it's tough it's
tough Amo Kelly did the best that he
could you know I mean to keep his team
in the gang I mean but when you go I
mean two for 18 into the postseason
that's not going to get it done and also
I mean what got the Dbacks into the
postseason the way they run the base the
way they play the game the way they are
aggressive and I don't seen that these
last couple of games and I think that's
something that they if they goingon to
try to have a a chance you know to try
to come back into the series they need
to get back into it you know running the
bases and and being aggressive and
taking some greater bats you know and uh
we see it you know in the postseason
pitching is always dominant I mean
that's that's history but when you face
a Philadelphia Philly you know lineup I
mean that lineup is tough but Marl Kelly
i t my cup you know he he went through
the lineup three times and keep the team
um in the game you know just the Diamond
Back couldn't take advantage and uh the
big reason for that is is is what we
were just talking about great pitching
almost perfect pitching perfect plan to
approach the the Arizona Diamondbacks
and and kudos to the Diamondbacks to
make it
to where they are the way they did but
man I I don't get enough of Nola enough
of Ranger Suarez you know enough of uh a
Wheeler and and then the arms they throw
at you let's say one of those guys like
Nola today in in what seemed to be an
easy game for him cuz he didn't even
break a sweat and then they unload
Hoffman they unload Str yeah different
arm I mean from different angles and
none of them finishes it is amazing to
to have what the Philadelphia philes up
and right now they have the aura that
you see in those teams that are ready to
win a World Series the look in their eye
P tell them it's easy all you have to do
is just strike out everyone you face on
the way to the hall of fame that's right
to the bank we go where no visiting team
wants to go the fans were there since
morning we talked about them having
steak and eggs there arinola Merill
Kelly sharing the duties on the mound in
game two and in true Philly we were
waiting for this we were watching this
going home run in the first yep Trey
Turner since August 4th has been
Unstoppable in a Phillies uniform he
knew it off the bat too and The Crowd
Goes Bananas they lean on you one to
nothing Phillies from a different angle
why not oh that's so pretty so pretty
that's a Dean D John they can swing
through the fences and they can play
defense for days from one knee you
kidding me Alec bom awesome diving stop
throwing out Gabriel Moreno cross a
diamond it was textbook it was almost
like the ball got past him already
that's that's what the the good ones do
they know how to pick the Hop and going
from last year I hate this place because
he was struggling defense to making
these plays all postseason long man that
man has turned it was I hate this bleep
in place we can't say that I can't
technically down the middle yes sir gule
sorber he usually crushes them not that
time such a dude thank you sir strong
dude two to nothing Phillies and Ro to
Epic catches by Nick castios in October
remember game three last year's World
Series his defense on full display Evan
Longoria deep to right uh but he's got
it give me enough room there and
congratulated by Yan roas in the
meantime arinola was a story the offense
as well but he was Flawless navigating
this Diamondback's lineup with ease just
as his rotation Zach wheeler did in game
one they have a two-headed monster that
is out of this world for all for Domo
Christian Walker like it was nothing
these are awesome hitters two to nothing
Phillies and in the bottom of the six
kind of unraveled in case you forgot
Kyle schwarber here to remind you that's
more like it saw four change UPS in that
at bat that one will do solo shot off
Merl Kelly no soup for you read to
nothing ding Johnson instead was there
our B right here that I feel they took
all their the breath away from the yeah
the wind out of their sails right real M
you know two big hit ton9 three RBI and
that was their our bat right there that
he fought and came through with that two
run dble I'm always fascinated when a
guy can call an incredible game and
contribute at the pl and and that's
what's been key uh all season long yeah
the big guys have have stepped that we
expect those guys but as you said
they're no outs in the lineup and
they're making sure that the world is
reminded after you get by them we still
have guys that can hit thises Brandon
Marsh wet his hair every at that what
it's like 18 times a day we heard it's
the hair and the beard CU his mom really
doesn't like it just for good measure
Alec foam the game got away from them in
the sixth inning left Center scoring
Bryce Harper and Kyle schwarber and the
Phillies just going away 10 to nothing
was your final in game two of the NLCS
at Citizens Bank Park they were all over
Arizona they won game5 to3 and they are
heading to the desert on a happy flight
you can say that again feeling good
about life arinola should feel pretty
good about his performance wow look at
this multi Homer games in the 2023
postseason studs this is what you want
you want the heart of your order doing
exact cuz it allows everyone else to
relax right well the key is that they've
all continued to like feat off each
other it's like all right you do
something let me see if I can one up you
and you have all players that have been
able to do it all year long so it's not
like this is uncharacteristic of them
they are power hitters when they get
pitches to hit that they can handle they
have a chance to hurt you and they're
all doing it right now in the biggest
Time of the Season and I think a big
move was casano is dropping down uh to
the seventh spot it stretches their
lineup out that's where Mike St was I
mean Bryson stot was hitting he was down
there now they have a bit more balanced
lineup stot who's been key and clutch
all year long and I think it may have
pissed castanos off cuz he's gone down
there and decided you know what I'm
going to do damage and when you do that
we talking about stretching the lineup
you you may have a in a bat where like I
can pitch around this guy but you always
looking a pitch ah head a b head and
you're looking at what's next and you
can't mix it match when we used to play
get the Lefty up get the right up he has
this pitch has to face three hitters so
by casano dropping down and and stock
going up it has balanced and stretched
their lineup out and also to add to that
that the success that Castellanos is
been able to have has allow the other
guys to actually get better pitches to
hit and and that that makes you take on
a bat a lot more relaxed than you would
if you have someone struggling behind
you and and even even at roas that that
was that was at the end of the lineup
got some pitches to hit the kid is young
enough and he doesn't really understand
what to do right now in the postseason
but he's going to click for him pretty
soon it's going to click by watching
those guys take a bath he's going to
feed off and he's going to be a lot
better and just as an aside I was
watching Bryce Harper and thinking this
is the Superstar in our sport he's not a
natural born first baseman and he just
says no problem you need me you don't
see that every day Albert with
superstars of the game definitely that's
a tough procision I mean they say this
first baseman AR no athlete I mean say
that say the same thing about P one
thing the Kendall always told me you
know hey for your infielder to win a go
glove you have to be a go go first
baseman and Harper have made some big
play not just in the postseason you know
in the regular season also so I give all
the credit you know a lot of hard work
that he has put into uh his work at
first base yeah all the credit to Bryce
Harper in that lineup but Aaron Nola
deserves his due curveball and a string
Ron kept saying that during the it kind
of stuck with me he was masterful when
he locates the fast ball it was magic he
just navigated that lineup Pedro with
ease and you know what he he had that
plan he knew that he couldn't get Ambush
and that's the mo for the Diamondbacks
so he came out of the poen making
pitches right away his first pitch of
the game was a fast ball Up and Away on
Carol letting him know I'm not going to
let you Ambush anything around the plate
and then from there on he just became
Picasso painting the corners a
masterpiece for for him I can call him
the cat now because he doesn't even
sweat I mean a roll with the
nicknames I'm tell
you hey who who's doing the writing for
you who's writing everything nobody I
just figured out this guy didn't even
break us I know he was chilly and but so
what what was his nickname now the cat
the
cat yeah I don't know the cat I mean
guys came up first pitch fastball and
then second time through the order it
was curveball so it's like you have no
way to gauge a game plan and he's also
reading he says okay if you came out
aggressive this time on that fast ball
let me switch it up maybe you're
thinking you're going to get that let me
switch it up and people forget how good
the curveball is you saw it the hitters
look confused especially when it was in
a spot where you thought he might throw
it and they still had no chance to hit
it and and not only that when he saw
himself in situations where he needed to
make a pitch he went to the chain jaap
and fortunately for him he had it too
and so he showed me today how you you're
almost perfect in a big game and and
Nola pitched literally perfect the
entire game a couple of pitches went up
a little bit and some of them they he
had been so so long around the strike
zone that they were chasing when they
saw something that they thought was
going to be in the strike zone they
chased it and it wasn't so that that's
almost like pitching perfect baseball
yeah but that's like you say you know
back up to everything start from early
in the game you know how he set those
pitch going inside to the righty inside
to the Lefty you know and like hey
another the thing that he was doing
really well was painting that corner
starting that two simmer a lot of the
Diamond Bus guy they were giving up on
that Sinker you know and we just coming
back and painting that corner so but
everything start you know setting up
early in the in the game hey I'm GNA
come in on you then I'm going to throw
you a Chena and when you're looking for
that Sinker I'm going to throw you that
breaking ball and when you canol the
game like that it's it's tough as a
hitter I don't care who you are it's
just really tough as a hit set the tone
beautifully game one and two went to
Philly game three is Thursday on TBS